let's bring in mark thiessen former
george w bush speechwriter a fox news
contributor i i want to just show you
that there's many democrats who have
basically tried to distance themselves
from the biden administration and have
said to the white house like we do not
think this is a good idea i think you
and i agree on something mark when
senator coons
who is very close to
president biden says this to me that was
basically the white house saying go out
there and float this trial balloon and
see how we're going to do with trying to
not end title 42 what do you think
yeah i agree i think senator coons is
there's no one closer to him fellow
delaware democrat uh if he's saying this
i think that there may be maybe a sign
that they're going to reverse this this
is this is
political kryptonite for democrats i
mean the the political morning console
poll came out last week showed 56 of
americans opposed lifting title 42 which
would make it the most unpopular
decision joe biden has made as president
i mean we're talking the iraq withdrawal
i mean the afghan withdrawal everything
else this would be the most unpopular
decision he's made and you've got these
vulnerable democrats like like mark
kelly in in arizona
catherine cordes masto in nevada and
also
maggie hassan in new hampshire who have
come out against this why is maggie
hassan concerned about this because new
hampshire is nowhere near the border
it's because of fentanyl it's not just a
surge of illegal migrants coming over
the border it's a surge of fentanyl
fentanyl deaths reach record levels in
2021 and they they now exceed uh they
now exceed uh gun murders and and
homicides and gun and gun shootings
across the country in terms of cause of
death so this is going this is good the
the border disaster has an impact across
the country and it's going to have an
impact across the country at the polls
what needs to be emphasized is the
democrats specifically are calling for
this as you rightly point out chris
coons
i mean
he's a brother in arms in the state of
delaware beto o'rourke in the state of
texas wants to be governor he's against
it
uh henry cuellar has been out spoken
about it for some time senator masto and
nevada i think she's the first latina
the senate has ever had and she's
against it also
with that as a backdrop here is kevin
mccarthy with perhaps
perhaps a line of campaigning for
republicans over the next six months
before midterms watch
what americans want need and deserve is
a clear common sense alternative and
that's what's happening with the house
republicans we will secure our border to
stop this immigration crisis but more
importantly to stop the fentanyl that is
coming into america that's the
difference of why the president's
approval ratings are so low and that's
why america will make a new course and
republicans will take the majority crime
the border drugs how likely is it mark
that when republicans take control of
the house the senate and the white house
someday
they will make it a policy to finish the
wall
oh i think it's it's uh very likely and
it and also restore the remain in mexico
policy restore the safe country safe
third country agreements that that
president trump negotiated where people
have to apply for asylum this is the
problem is that we should not be
depending on a public health measure to
prevent us from having an open border
joe biden has been protected from the
consequences of his decisions at the
border by title 42 by the pandemic
because he got rid of the remain in
mexico policy where people had to apply
for asylum there he got rid of the safe
third country agreements he stopped
basically deportations we have the
lowest number of deportations in history
the only thing that has
prevented an absolute deluge of people
coming across this border has been
titled 42 and so if he lifts that
americans will finally if we think the
border has been a disaster for the last
year it's going to be a disaster like
they've never seen and of course they're
going to pay a political price for that
point being in all that you can't trust
democrats i mean that that's that's the
case republicans are going to make if if
they control the house the senate in the
white house mark nice to see you thanks
for coming back on a monday morning